lariats Ross Tucker good to have you on
the Dan Patrick show today I'm filling
in for dan I guess can you just give us
an update as to what we know right now
because this stuff with Cardell Hayes
dad and the police department it's it's
kind of more than a coincidence or at
least it seems like it to me right and
just up the street right now is the
police have arrested and you mentioned
the suspect Cardell Hayes who didn't
flee the scene of the accident and the
shooting he stayed there and New Orleans
Police Department saying the press
conference yesterday that uh you know he
will smith was shot several times in the
back and the source though and the Hayes
was arrested and charged with
second-degree murder and yeah the the
the when we don't know if it's totally
connected yet but there isn't a side
story through this where will smith was
at dinner about an hour before he was
shot to death with a former NOPD
commander and this this commander was
part of a lawsuit involving the shooting
death of phases father ten years ago and
so if you have to you have to be
skeptical I'm saying maybe this might be
harder do we know we don't know but all
we do know is that Hayes's in charged
with second-degree murder of Will Smith
and he's got a million-dollar bail and
what and this town is because when it
comes to crimes and murder I I think in
new orleans and their citizens have
become desensitized and I've talked to
so many people that hope that this
incident can kind of wake up this city
to what's going on because like Will
Smith is one of
of the classier guys you can find in the
NFL and with the saints organization and
he's gone 34 his wife was also shot uh
she was shot in the leg I believe twice
last I heard she is in stable condition
but was Will Smith leave behind a wife
and three children and really a
community and an ephah in New Orleans
and sinks community and uh an NFL
community who's at a loss Larry are
there any theories or logic as to why
Cardell Hayes stayed I mean I you know
obviously I never shot anybody but I
can't imagine that I would just stay
there I mean there had to be some
reasoning why he just stayed there is
very Furies out there or speculation
well his lawyer after uh after scorpions
yesterday their case is that will smith
was the aggressor in the incident and
like there there some there's some
differences of stories depending on
which side you know who was involved in
in creating the car rack and uh but yeah
I I find that curious as well and so
right now all we're doing with this
state to feel kind of Ennis infancy as
far as being investigated yeah i think
that is that is something to where we're
going to have to find out more why he
was with stay around he may believe he
wasn't self-defense without Lois none of
us were there that's we're going to find
out as this escape received we're
talking with Larry hold or he's covered
the st. since 2006 for the New Orleans
times-picayune and nola.com Larry you
went to one Pro Bowl would you call him
a great player or just a good player I
think he's a Saints great for sure and
if it's bad that's our our media Cora I
had elected him into the same Hall of
Fame in March and announcement wasn't
going to come down until
it may so he's considered one of the
all-time seems great within this
community but yet he was kind of that
stabilizer on defenseless 2004
first-round pick and if one of the first
round picks in st. history that lived up
to the expectations and that Super Bowl
year and for several other years
happened in the defense along with
Jonathan Vilma and really was he was
their main pass rusher for several years
and it's but yeah one Pro Bowl a
double-digit sacks and actually did
another Pro Bowl one year he had
double-digit sacks but but really was
one of those favorable main forces and
that 2009 Super Bowl run for the Saints
and just known also as a quiet guy and
involved in this community and as as
eerie as it is he a few years ago he
tweeted something about New Orleans
let's stop this violence and
unfortunately he died because of
violence in the city what kind of person
Larry I know at least I didn't know him
personally but based on Twitter for
everybody all of his former teammates it
seems like really speaking glowingly of
him yeah i would say someone who is not
this rah-rah guy but someone who can
always kind of find a way to relate to
anyone really talk to anyone i talked to
one of his former teammates yesterday
Scott shambling line back those things
for several several years basically
through almost the entire time whilst
mrs. things as well and he said look we
they come from vastly different
backgrounds but they will smith just had
a knack of relating to him and relating
to everyone else around him really uh no
known for being a family guy and it's a
guy who gave back and like I said it was
he wasn't about you know the the
showboating and all of that and I think
that's one of the one of the reasons why
he was so endeared by his teammates
by the fan base here and just that you
know I 34 years old is he what he was
last on the same team in 2013 and it's I
still think the this area in new orleans
in the Saints communities is in shock
and I think they'll be in shock for a
long time just wondering why this could
happen for someone who didn't seem to
deserve it Larry why is New Orleans so
desensitized to it why are things so bad
down there right now look I do think
that there's just a brazen attitude that
that's grown within this committee and
it's been here for a long time and I
know people like to talk about will you
know when can it stop and there's always
you know there's excuse well their lack
of a police force Oh police force has
been down this has been going back since
Hurricane Katrina when when the numbers
went down but if but I think a part of
it you can you can point to the
education system look last night in
yesterday's Howard Matthew who grew up
in troubled areas in New Orleans was
very frank about the conditions of of
New Orleans and things he went through
and let some of those things he fell
into and I think that's part of the
problem as well so if it's a multi-layer
in here in New Orleans and I don't know
if it's going to change anytime soon
there's a hope that that something can
change because of this but I do think
people here in New Orleans probably
aren't holding your breath because we
probably said this many many times with
many many incidents but this is probably
the most high-profile incident we've
seen in the last several years Larry
really appreciate the time thanks so
much yeah thanks for off appreciate you
having the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you